you can't be like I only don't feel
negative things it's the fundamental
attribution error which is something
good happens it's because of me if
something bad happens it's because of my
surroundings it's like well if you flip
it then if something good happens it's
because my surroundings something bad
happens because it may so if you flip
that as your fundamental like way that
you see the world then you don't get
higher in your own Supply because when
something good happened it wasn't
because I mean if something bad happened
it was because of me so I think you just
have to flip where you're emphasizing if
you're somebody who like tends to be
really a little bit more ego driven
needs the positive reinforcement then
flip it the other way if you're
somebody's a little bit more insecure
then you can feed a little bit more into
the positive but I think the end is kind
of the middle path